[Music]
how are you guys so um
by show of hands how many of you are is
my mic on are you guys doesn't feel like
it do you guys yeah I can go loud I
don't know if you guys are doing it like
before noise I don't think I touched it
no worries I can wait a second oh that's
right you're right I did I'll take this
okay this awesome you're right sorry I
that's the daily be mic sorry about that
by show of hands how many of you have
context for me raise your hands and how
many don't okay good so I'll give you a
little background and I'll talk a little
bit and then we'll open it up to Q&A cuz
I just want to get a sense so I'm an
entrepreneur and I'm an entrepreneur
that probably spends a disproportionate
amount of time looking at consumer
behavior and have basically spent the
last 20 30 years of my life reverse
engineering what I think is actually
happening with people's attention and
that's what brought me to email
marketing in 1996 when I had 90 percent
open rates it's what brought me to
Google AdWords the day Google AdWords
started with five cents a click it's
what brought me to YouTube seven months
after YouTube started and started one of
the big first shows that was longer than
a minute it's what made me an early
investor in Twitter and Facebook and
Tumblr and it's my currency my intuition
on where you're spending your time and
and usually I'm just a little bit faster
than the next guy or gal in executing on
those platforms and then I spent all my
time trying to figure out how to bring
value in that new paradigm shift so for
example for the ones that do follow me
you know that I'm very obsessed with
voice right now and so because I believe
that Alexa and Google home and Apple
home pod and whatever you know Alibaba
or 10 Center the big Asian players do
that everybody and six years will have a
device or or the voice will be in the
paint or in the building but that most
of you will be in
acting with a voice-activated AI
environment and to me now what do I do
I by narrowly decided that's happening
the same way I by nearly 10 years ago
thought the cellphone would be the most
important thing in our lives which is
what led me to betting on the platforms
that were being built on top of it and I
believe in my intuition I execute within
those white spaces and so intuitive
understanding of consumer behavior
dating sites in the 2000s when it was
taboo and now it's mainstream so
believing in my intuition jumping into
new territory it's real estate I'm in
the real estate business I believe some
place is gonna be good I start building
I learned the space better than the next
person and I beat him a player in that
domain obviously for a lot of you it
really became obvious to you in the
social media domain over the last ten
years but it was happening in the web
1.0 domain with search and Adwords it
was just I was doing it for a liquor
store behind-the-scenes and I was
starting from zero
I think voice is gonna be my third
chapter and that's it and then for you
guys I think a lot about supply and
demand
I spent a lot of time on supply and
demand of attention which is what I've
just been talking about for a few
minutes and then I also to be very frank
with you think about supply and demand
of entrepreneurs there's never been more
startups lucky for me because it's fun
and it's cool entrepreneurship has been
put on a huge pedestal it is crazy to me
that you know that there's celebrity
around entrepreneurship but that's the
case and that means there's a
vulnerability that means a lot of people
that shouldn't be entrepreneurs are and
what I mean by that is everybody should
try you're more than welcome
it's just I'm scared that there's a lack
of self-awareness and everybody does
binary things like like the same kids
that blindly went to MBAs are now
blindly doing startups and let me just
remind everybody number eleven at
Facebook made a lot more money than
number
99% of companies so you know when I go
into a room like this I'm less worried
about marketing arbitrage of attention
I'm more worried about are you
self-aware enough of what kind of
founder or entrepreneur are you and do
you know how to surround yourself with
the things that you need to be
successful instead of blindly thinking
you can do everything and then are you
doubling down or tripling down on your
strengths and are you putting that
pieces together to be successful in what
your ambition is and are you aware of
all the vulnerabilities of what you're
doing and how are you combating those
and most of all are you building a
business based on the way the world is
right now without anticipating what the
world's gonna look like in 36 months by
the time you actually have something so
those are the themes on my mind
I'd love to kick off with a little bit
of Q&A and see where you guys take this
and then if you know if I need to jump
back in and change the tone of
conversation I'm happy to do so but does
anybody have a question
Marie I just gotta open up an asset I
just recently got a power profile on
Lincoln
okay and this morning I asked my agent
because I didn't have a question for you
no worries I didn't take two I didn't
okay sounds cool cool what's your name
my name is Cecily they'll say okay so
this one comes from Jessica Morgan can
you describe a time you felt lost in her
career path what did you do so I think
for me I've been very felt super lost
the first 18 years of my life because I
wasn't a student and in the 80s and 90s
there was no such thing as
entrepreneurship in America and the only
way that you traded was based on how
good of a student you were and so for
the first you know kind of from six kind
of from ten to eighteen I had a lot of
pressure being thrown at me by teachers
and parents of my friends that basically
painted me as a loser because I was
getting D's and F's even though I was
making $3,000 a weekend selling baseball
cards I was losing which you know built
up a good skin made me very prepared for
entrepreneurship the only only time
since I was 22 for the last 20 years
that I've felt lost was when I knew that
it was time for me to transition out of
my family business and I was worried
that it would hurt my dad's feelings
right luckily what manifested in that
two to three years where it was kind of
like starting to build was my dad also
was struggling because I was starting to
be the real operator of his business and
he was feeling less of a man and less of
the man so as that I hit a crescendo
point for both of us
it actually became easy to leave the
business because we were both winning he
got to be the boss again and I got to go
on to do other things so it would be the
only you know - I don't want to manifest
a [ __ ] story I've I've never felt
lost in operating this is what I was
meant to do probably no different than
somebody who's meant to be a soccer
player or meant to be a musician like
purebred you know I really am I really
really am
I never was capable of doing anything
but selling and branding and marketing
and business e-business long before it
was cool so I got very lucky it's why I
really push people to do what they're
passionate about because sometimes you
get lucky and the world comes to you and
that's absolutely what's happened to me
the thing that I always was has now
become the thing and that's really
worked out questions and listen I you
know just to give you guys context
doesn't know a lot of you may not know
who I am I've invested in over 200
startups like I'm very comfortable
answering a very detailed subtle
question that you may have on your mind
for your business be selfish that's what
Q&A is about and a lot of times the
question you have is 60 percent of the
audience is also thinking of version of
it so don't feel like you have to come
up with a question that's available to
anybody go real selfish we have some
time here hello
help friends to find high-end work at
social media influences for market
mandates so my question is more personal
I started this business cause two years
ago and the first year was like finally
there was a lot of pitching and
everything and very exciting in the
second year comes and I'm always in the
office coaching people scaling the
business you're managing you know
managing so what is the next thing I cuz
I've been coaching for six months
coaching your employees more coaching
well so here's the real question if you
don't like it and you like the hunting
and not the farming you need to find a
farming partner you understand right and
so that either comes in the form of an
actual partner or you bring in a
managing director and she or he is
really good at operational and HR
aspects and you're out building the
brand and hunting for business
to make it go sure but I think first of
all you have to deploy patience when
you're small and you can't maybe afford
the proper farming partner you've got to
eat [ __ ] you've got to make choices
you've got you've got to answers you
either work more so that you hunt from
7:00 p.m. to midnight or you deploy
patience cool but don't underestimate
patience patience is usually the reason
people lose it's hard you have something
to prove you want to get something with
the money you want to scratch the chip
on your shoulder to prove everybody that
you weren't a loser because you had DS
and FS I understand why patience is hard
but it is absolutely the superpower of
most successful businesses and it is
something that most young people never
want to do and then you have the
subtleties of an Asian culture where
there's a lot of conflict with parents
if you're taking that risk so the
quicker you're successful the quicker
you can say see mom but a lot of times
that becomes the flaw because you try to
overextend and then you break the whole
thing so be thoughtful you know the I
told you so
ironically is even more sweet if it
takes longer because then people are
building more cynicism because you
didn't do it fast which makes it even
more fun when you stick it to him
there's nothing more fun than losing
3210 going into the fourth quarter and
then winning - many people want to win
30 - 10 in the first three quarters and
then lose because it feels better up
front I care about the finish line not
the starting post
yes good i say i thank you and i'll say
that videos you're less metal and more
thoughtful person thank you
hi great it said since we're really good
and say and I'll tell you this parent if
there was a thousand people here I
wouldn't I think the context drives my
behavior I'm always listening right so
Wendy rock and I are on camera I'm
envisioning 400,000 people which drives
my energy up
you think this is thoughtful mellow you
should have dinner with me for two hours
you know what I mean and so the context
is always the driver of my behavior I'm
already interested I believe it's the
biggest space for consumer behavior
going into the next decade as a consumer
product the way fitness was in the 90s
me doing meditation yes I and I'm still
not yes I did it once on a podcast for
fun
but I've never done it since yes makes
you excited about the space and what are
some key transfers so I don't think the
person that observes things has to be a
user of those things or look like the
person that you know some of the
greatest coaches in athletics never
played the game so it's about the
ability to synthesize the psychology
what what why am I so excited about it
because the brain is the operating
system of the human being and we haven't
even begun to explore it because we've
lived in such an environment of
prosperity in the world that we are now
into second and third generation wealth
in a lot of places which means we have
anxiety about dumb [ __ ]
which leads us to these kind of trends I
think we've become more educated about
our health from a physical and food
standpoint and humans are incredible
we're survivors
so I always bet on humans even when I'm
scared about macro political issues in
North Korea us you know I always say to
myself the fact that we're still here is
something you have to bet on and we've
gotten better in our life expectancy and
I believe that meditation is the unlock
of the next chapter that people will
live longer and happier once they start
really getting into that game and I'll
be very honest with you I think I was
born gifted I think I'm meditating while
I'm talking to you right now I think I
feel like I'm the tough read I'm an
enigma because of my personality but I
think the people that know me better
have been around a little bit longer
have a pretty good read in my ground
nests I'm balanced in my extremities and
so I know the benefits of a very
peaceful mind I think maybe it was
handed to me or the circumstances handed
it to me but I wish it on everybody
and if meditation is a gateway to that
feeling which I believe intuitively it
could be it's going to be a big deal now
anytime something is a big deal business
people come in and so you've gonna have
a lot of people from these parts of the
world in the other places where this has
been common culture for a long time who
are gonna be mad at the American you
know business DNA of turning meditation
into SoulCycle and coca-cola but that is
what's gonna happen and I look at that
as a positive because I think anything
that gets a lot more people into a good
place it's just good and if some people
have to make a lot of money to make that
happen I'm cool with that too because I
like capitalism I think it's interesting
so I'm it's as black and white as any
trend for me more than I think that the
Sun will come up tomorrow do I believe
that meditation is going to be a very
substantial Commerce trade over the next
30 to 40 years now depent now becomes
the next question what are you gonna do
about that what is somebody who here
just got inspired gonna do about that
are you gonna be the fashion brand are
you gonna be the app are you gonna be
the food compliment - are you gonna be
the studio location are you gonna build
the high luxury retreats what are you
gonna do about that is the question well
you're welcome
questions
but very upside serve a couple of things
you've talked about already resonate
with me and go to a question or girls
anyway great you just be talking about
happiness
yes'm interesting happiness so
personally my background is I started on
a corporate job and a flag on there
isn't what it started I was basically
that person you're talking about the
vulnerability of the market in terms of
getting involved in startups
I did take because it had that was no
longer the cool thing to do I wasn't the
natural part for people so I started
with what a lot of people think of as
quite a boring job and then I'm moving
to toast a lot of you and then you're
very interesting and that's what I do
now however love startups mind you lots
of interesting stuff personally I love
it
this means I get a lot of people
reaching out to me to figure out how to
do it themselves for a transition
understood sir and do you now see that
as a white space that you want to play
in okay that's right of course most
people are unhappy sure because
something that I think resonates most
about all your contact me is your sort
of focus on ladies yes that's too cool
and I've told me a long time to figure
this out to go through my sort of
professional gratification what it all
comes back to is the most important
thing for me is my habits
yes cannot separate personal that's
exactly right so I'm that's good I was
walking through a lot of people who are
at race we need for help too
that's right one thing I'm struggling
with when I speak to these people is
sort of breaking through that wall which
admittedly took me a few years to be
able to really focus on honesty it's
it's it's radical candor yeah
it's pressure you know it's where people
confuse my content where people struggle
with me up front is I'm making them
uncomfortable because I'm suffocating
their [ __ ] I get it it's because
you're at a place where I used to be
probably at some point too I just
stuffed for me to recall it's you're
deploying empathy you're a good guy it's
not fun to be disliked like I don't like
being disliked on first impression I
just know it's my responsibility because
I have a gift of communication and now I
feel almost a sense of responsibility
you know I mean the answer is
self-awareness to all questions if you
have excitement or energy towards
helping people whether professionally or
just kind of random the answer is
radical candor and suffocation which is
not a normal trait for a lot of people I
hate being disliked which is crazy
because a lot of the way I roll publicly
creates 25 to 40 percent dislike on
initial contact but I'm gonna win in
legacy because I get a hundred meals a
week a hundred emails a week that just
start with I first started hating you
how many people here to consume my
content in any shape or form raise your
hands high I want everybody see this for
some pie higher don't be scared okay how
many of you the first time you saw me
thought I was a [ __ ] artist or
didn't love it raise your hands this is
a very interesting insight but you know
what's cool about legacy
it's truthful and so I would I would
tell you that if you're trading on
legacy like you will start gaining just
in the same way that you realize that me
too
you'll start gaining sharper edges to
get people there quicker because you
could bounce around and pander with it
or you could just get right to the punch
line getting to the punch line is the
beginning of the process of them winning
that's not you that's why you've got to
roll with honey and then vinegar right
you've got a hat you know it's like
being a fighter
it's like MMA right you've got a you you
know this like I can't even tell you've
got to throw different kind of angles
the other question is you know my dad
I've worked on him more than any person
on earth he's not it's not gonna happen
so like some people prefer to live
within their non truth then you move on
now there's different ways to move on
it's not like you cut them out of your
life but you have to be also self-aware
and accept things as well something so
much one can do you know you got it
it's a super interesting painting man
what's crazy is I think technology is
exposing us it's unbelievable how I see
this whole thing and I'm putting it on
film I will not be able to see this be
true I believe the next 50 years is a
giant step backwards for human beings in
the short-term because we're about to be
exposed who we actually are and we're
not gonna like a lot of things that we
see right that's brexit that's Trump
that's a lot of this stuff I think
though that that's gonna put us a Hut in
a hundred-year macro much further along
because once we actually get to that
point we're gonna start fixing it so I
think it's me super interesting hello
how are you good
Oh Jamie
yes
yes
the client sort of the problem
correct correct well the first thing I
do in that scenario which is a very
tricky one is I ask them how they
measure all the [ __ ] they're
actually doing right so whatever you're
talking about right let's talk about a
fashion retailer brick-and-mortar store
they can be mad at me that the metrics
don't prove to them that the pictures on
Instagram and Facebook sell blouses and
I'm empathetic to that though I'm more
than capable of driving a transactional
sale versus a branding sale which is a
more short-term play than a long-term
play I'm thrilled but before I even let
them beat me up on the lack of metrics
of my environment I asked them to tell
me how they justify the print and
outdoor that they do the answer is they
don't have an answer
they've just accepted it it's kind of
like religion right so I'm okay with
that
mmm my answer to your question is very
simple you have to understand that
you're in client services which means
you're not the ultimate decision-maker
which means you have to deal in the
reality of what you're dealing with I
don't have a single client of the
hundred fifteen million dollars in
revenue that vaynermedia will make this
year that spends their money the way I
would if I ran their business and I'm
Gary B zero so I think that you have to
be accepting of the reality the
situation but never waver from your
strategic point of view I've never
accepted that bullcrap from a client I
will always push back on my belief and I
let the chips fall where they may
whether we don't you know what we we
don't ever win business pitches because
we just get handed business because if
we're actually going up against somebody
else we are not the consumable agency
because I'm not willing to waver to make
them feel good in the same way that Sam
just asked about self-awareness I'm not
in the business to make a client feel
good and make them justify programmatic
banners and justify print I don't
believe in it so you know it's very easy
to measure Instagram and Facebook if you
drive them to a conversion
make a coupon piece of content and drive
them to stores and see how that does
against direct mail tell them to do that
same coupon in a print magazine
no no that's branding we have to put a
pretty picture it's it's complete horse
crap and it's why big businesses of
today are on the verge of not being
around tomorrow because a lot of their
behavior doesn't map the reality of the
world that we live in you're welcome
she just looked you dead in the face and
said I'm gonna move that was that was
super gangster you were right there you
raised her hand she looked you right in
face and said now I'm gonna I'm gonna
move it that was honestly the favorite
part of my whole day so far hey come on
no kidding yeah what town how close is
that the brusque awesome guess they
don't group the brothers smart engineers
developers does they make sensible we
have one of the top growing websites out
there for this space understand
specification about 20% we can we can do
what I'm throw-in faster and I'm trying
to figure out what the best channels of
what the best way to go it is just
content if it's something else it was
like help me be very like I think you go
above the line and below the line so
what I would do is I would write white
papers and manifestos and distribute
them through LinkedIn and Facebook and
then I would do Google AdWords I think
you will do very like in the early
nature of crypto so many people are
searching and I think if you find the
long tail of a couple of different
search queries you know how to get
involved in the crypto business like I
think there's a lot of long tail search
queries that will probably be
disproportionately ry+ for you in crypto
non-paid why I told I told this agree
let's talk about it if I think that's
fill I think that's ideological so if
you can find an arbitrage and paid that
is more ROI positive for you than what
you're paying it's a hell of a lot more
scalable and more interesting I think
unpaid is philosophically interesting
but I I'm not against paid when it's an
arbitrage that is massively ROI positive
and when there's new spaces and crypto
is new there's a lot of arbitrage and
paid but there's a couple other ways you
could go
you could start a weekly podcast about
crypto and there's a lot of thing
you know when you go non-paid Ramon the
biggest thing that you have to wrap your
head around is you're running a marathon
non-pay it's incredible I'm a big
non-paid guy
I'm also 15 years in the making so
faster and organic don't match the
content always plays you're gonna have
to have a unique point of view and you
have to understand distribution but I'm
in for it
I just wouldn't especially when you're
running a business wouldn't I
you would absolutely speed up the
process on running paid because of the
interest craft of crypto is so easy both
an intent and targeting it's just it's
vibrant to run paid in new dynamics
because there's a lot more search query'
going on because people don't understand
it and so I would give that a lot of
thought how are you but good because
getting in town not for me as a young
natural 27 or 30 now my peers are all
like way above wouldn't be nd once I
come when I came in they all like should
me though yes the second thing is by
promoting providing alternative
perspective to my students whenever this
counseling students and all that they
are unsure what to do next
some mental issues often said really
taught me a lot thank you and the last
one is I think because one for me is
that I used to always think that out of
opinion
yes odd you made me realize that I am
NOT an interpreter but yes I think
that's a big thing for me so that comes
to my question is that I have a big
ambition I believe education has the
power to change lives and for me my
childhood dream to be a lecturer a
business model by his body already
accomplished it right now for me taking
what's next which is about legacy of a
currency for me and I want to give a
foundation of good schools to give back
to society so one question one thing I
have is that we talk about mission and
the willingness to hustle work I have a
mission but willingness to hustle for
that addition is lacking why
I passed my question myself as well
what's the real answer I also see it as
my parents and it's all set I think
that's a solution I think the biggest
thing is myself one that I am maybe I'm
scared of obsess all that data but no
I'm comfortable in uncomfortable
yeah but then I'm not sure the better I
can do it really but then I same time I
do that I can do it I think I think the
biggest thing that you you have to I
think both your answers are right I
think once you get into a place where
your failures are just yours they get a
lot less scary and you answered the
right thing whether it's your parents or
somebody else in your life the biggest
reason people don't take risks is they
worry about other people's opinions it
is I I wish you guys could feel what I
feel in my heart and in my soul I do not
care about a single person's point of
view about me while equally caring about
what you think about me it's a very
interesting contradiction
it's a subtlety but saying both your
parents and yourself it's it's you know
when I hear I'm scared to fail but I
feel like you can do it you're just
worrying about you're just worrying
about outside forces it's no different
than the way you like I love if my
professors of 40 50 60 year-olds when I
was 25 would a [ __ ] on me because I was
excited about sticking it to them later
and if I didn't and here's a big one and
I don't talk about this as much when I
fail I'm excited cuz it meant that I
deserved to fail I love the game so much
even at my own expense
like I can't be pumped about the fruits
of victory without equally respecting
the agony of the defeat I'm excited when
I fail I'm like okay tough guy
and the sleeker the sneaker this is
interesting to me why did I do this deal
it was win-win if it works I get to run
around with the legacy of being like the
first entrepreneur with a signature
sneaker and then you know it's kind of
cool right like every 20 years
entrepreneurs are just like athletes and
musicians that have sneakers I can sit
here in 20 years to be like you know the
way I thought about the first speaker
you know it's cool it's a it's a legacy
play of being strategically right but if
I fail it's ammo for my friends to make
fun of me like remember when you thought
you were so cool tough guy like it's
funny but I have to have that humility
as much as I have that confidence to be
able to do my thing you have to be okay
with losing I have a different question
for you which is if that's your and I
agree with you that education has the
chance to change the world because it's
already happened education changed the
world
my bigger question is I just want to
make sure that you're not overly
romantic of the format of the delivery
of the education so I'm fascinated by
everybody right now in our current state
being energy let me explain the fact
that we in society put a written
handwritten note on a pedestal as this
is some great gesture versus when we
text people is fascinating to me because
we've put the medium on a pedestal not
the action so you're telling me if I
write an incredible sixth sentence
empathetic love letter to my mom of my
admiration of her in text form that that
for some reason is less powerful than a
written handwritten note for that same
delivery just because we're anti
technology because we fear change I
laugh at that that's how I think about
education I do not believe in a lot of
ways that education is being dispersed
because it is in the selfish financial
interest of the disperser so one weird
insight could be that that's your unlock
that you believe in it but
subconsciously you know that the format
is [ __ ] welcome
one last lesson - hi Ariana from
Indonesia
I think foreplay gives your boys very
air from your ETA
thank you for our work another person
like you I'm really curious about how do
you manage your time between you and
your family yes and in previous section
you talked about escapism we have to be
you to have execution and my question is
what is your it's a team what is your my
escapism is the New York Jets for those
three hours 16 Sundays a year in the
fall and winter you could tell me that
the world is ending and I won't care
because that escapism is my pure quiet
zone and nothing in business technology
social unrest is in my mind all I'm
worried about is my guys score more
touchdowns than your guys right so
that's my escapism and some people use
film like I don't watch movies but I
love movies because I know that does
that for a lot of people to get wrapped
up in that story that's cool reading you
know I love people having their version
of escapism because it's the healthiest
thing I think it's got some nuances to
meditation so that's that as well it
comes down to work-life balance there's
a couple things that I think about first
of all I would argue to everybody that
the best way to become selfless is to
start by being selfish if you don't know
who you are and what you're about you
will lose so the first thing is I do not
crumble to current peer pressure of how
I should live my work-life balance I
think that modern parenting advice is
quite flawed and has historically been
flawed because it changes all the time
because it's generational
and it's macro political and so number
one I don't care what other parents tell
me if I work too much or don't work too
much I care about what my wife thinks I
care about how my kids are reacting and
most of all my friend I don't over judge
myself I know what my intent is
I want to be a great father I want to be
a great husband sometimes I'm over
delivering sometimes I'm under
delivering I'm always trying this is
also a specific chapter in my life so
because I squeezed it so hard in these
four years next year I get to bring
Misha and Xander to this trip to
Singapore paid for by somebody who's
gonna pay me two hundred thousand
dollars to give a speech and fly my kids
over and I'm gonna take them to this
like you know life's about give and take
there's no right or wrong there's what's
your thing are my are my six weeks of
vacation of deep down time higher
quality time then somebody who makes fun
of me that comes home at six o'clock
every night but doesn't really spend
time with their family like I'm not
pandering I'm living in my reality and
my reality is for people and I'm always
putting a pulse on it while making sure
I'm not full of [ __ ] and conveniently
creating a narrative that works for me
because of my passion which I do just
like anybody else
and I just keep trying and I just keep
trying and I find angles two years ago I
had two weeks vacation now I'm at six
and seven that's a big shift for me I
almost took all of August off it's not
heard of you know so I'm just adjusting
I'm just adjusting but never over
judging myself because I don't think
anybody's doing it better I just think
people are doing it differently that's
how I handle it you're welcome
[Applause]
[Music]